Oh
well first of all we have to understand
that they're unlikely to speak English
unless they've been studying us for a
long time and that it's hard enough to
communicate properly between different
people on on this planet or all part of
the same species that the cultural Gulf
some misunderstandings are of course
notorious we're now dealing with a
completely separate species then you
have to think what on earth have we got
in common so I feel that our
communication would be we will want to
let ET know our finest achievements the
things we're most proud of and if you
just go out on the street and ask people
well what do you think are our finest
achievements chances are that you'll be
told a Beethoven symphony or Picasso
painting or something like that and I
have no quarrel with that but the
problem is that our appreciation of
works of art and music are very much
tied to our cognitive system and an
alien whose brain is wired differently
probably wouldn't have any understanding
of it and said it would have any
understanding of politics or sport or
anything of that sort so be no point in
sending those things now there's one
thing we're all agreed that we must
share and that is mathematics
mathematics is universal it's it's
discovered by human beings but the rules
of mathematics are the same throughout
the universe and the laws of the
universe are mathematical relationships
so the underlying laws of physics we can
cast in mathematical form so if they are
communicating with us if they have
technology they will understand the laws
of physics and the nature of mathematics
these are things that we can share so it
seems to me that our communication will
begin in terms of mathematics and
physics so me I'm a mathematical
physicist so you might say well you
would say that wouldn't you but I really
do think that this is the common
currency of the cosmos and so we will
want to communicate about our
understanding of mathematical physics so
we could tell them things that we have
discovered in the realm of mathematical
physics but there's stuff that I would
like to know there are some famous
problems like how to bring gravitation
and quantum fees
six together the long sought after
theory of quantum gravity that's one
thing that I would like to know it may
be hard to understand the answer that
comes back there's something that's
perhaps a little easier there's a
quantity in the theory of quantum
electrodynamics called the
fine-structure constant so I'm getting
technical here it's a particular
quantity it's a fundamental constants of
nature has a value of about 1 over 137
nobody knows why that number is as it is
it's a pure number it doesn't matter
what units you use and it's it's long
been an interest of mine as to how that
number has arisen in nature why that
particular number and and none other so
I would like et - given the explanation
for that because the answer might be we
don't know either it's not clear that et
would be all-knowing